Toma lo que puede ser el invento más importante de los tiempos modernos:
las computadoras programables.
La historia estándar es que descienden de la tecnología militar,
ya que muchas de las primeras fueron diseñadas específicamente
para descifrar códigos en tiempo de guerra o calcular trayectorias de cohetes.
Pero de hecho, los orígenes de la computadora moderna
son mucho más lúdicos,
incluso más musicales,
lo que podrías imaginar.
La idea tras la flauta,
de simplemente soplar aire a través de tubos para hacer un sonido,
finalmente fue modificada para crear el primer órgano
hace más de 2.000 años.
A alguien se le ocurrió la brillante idea de producir sonidos
pulsando pequeñas palancas con nuestros dedos,
la invención del primer teclado musical.
Los teclados evolucionaron a partir de órganos a clavicordios a clavecines
al piano,
hasta mediados del siglo XIX,
cuando a un grupo de inventores finalmente se les ocurrió la idea
de utilizar un teclado no para producir sonidos, sino cartas.
De hecho, la primera máquina de escribir
originalmente se llamó "el clavicordio escritor".
Las flautas y la música han llevado a grandes avances aún más potentes.
Hace unos mil años,
a la altura del Renacimiento islámico,
tres hermanos en Bagdad diseñaron un dispositivo
que era un órgano automatizado.
Lo llamaron "el instrumento que se toca a sí mismo".
El instrumento era básicamente una caja de música gigante.
El órgano podía entrenarse para tocar melodías con el uso de instrucciones
codificadas por la colocación de pines en un cilindro giratorio.
Y si querías que la máquina tocara una canción diferente,
solo cambiabas a un nuevo cilindro con un código diferente.
Este instrumento fue el primero de su clase.
Era programable.
Conceptualmente, este fue un gran salto hacia adelante.
La idea de hardware y software
comenzó a pensarse por primera vez con esta invención.
Y este concepto increíblemente poderoso
no vino a nosotros como un instrumento de guerra o de conquista,
o necesidad en absoluto.
Vino de la extraña delicia de ver una máquina tocando música.
De hecho, la idea de máquinas programables
se mantuvo viva exclusivamente por la música por unos 700 años.
En la década de 1700, las máquinas que tocaban música
se convirtieron en los juguetes de la élite parisina.
Hombres del espectáculo utilizaban los mismos cilindros codificados
para controlar los movimientos físicos de lo que se llamó autómatas,
una especie temprana de robot.
Uno de los más famosos de esos robots
era, lo has adivinado, un flautista automatizado
diseñado por un brillante inventor francés
llamado Jacques de Vaucanson.
Y al Vaucanson ir diseñando su robot músico,
tuvo otra idea.
Si se podía programar una máquina para hacer sonidos agradables,
¿por qué no programarla para tejer patrones de color encantadores en tela?
En lugar de usar las clavijas del cilindro para representar notas musicales,
podrían representar hilos de diferentes colores.
Si quieres un nuevo patrón para tu tela,
solo programa un nuevo cilindro.
Este fue el primer telar programable.
Ahora bien, los cilindros eran demasiado costosos y consumía mucho tiempo hacerlos,
pero medio siglo después,
otro inventor francés llamado Jacquard
tuvo la brillante idea de utilizar tarjetas de papel perforadas
en vez de cilindros de metal.
El papel resultó ser mucho más barato y más flexible
como forma de programar el dispositivo.
Ese sistema de tarjetas perforadas inspiró al inventor victoriano Charles Babbage
para crear su máquina analítica,
la primera verdadera computadora programable
que se haya diseñado.
Y las tarjetas perforadas fueron usadas por los programadores informáticos
tan tarde como la década de 1970.
Así que hazte esta pregunta:
¿qué hizo realmente posible la computadora moderna?
Sí, la participación militar es una parte importante de la historia,
pero la invención de las computadoras también requirió otros componentes:
cajas de música,
robots que tocaban flauta,
teclados para clavicordio,
patrones de colores en telas tejidas
y eso es solo una pequeña parte de la historia.
Hay una larga lista de ideas y tecnologías que cambian el mundo
que salieron del juego:
museos públicos, caucho,
teoría de la probabilidad, el negocio de seguros
y muchas más.
La necesidad no siempre es la madre de la invención.
El estado de ánimo lúdico es fundamentalmente exploratorio,
la búsqueda de nuevas posibilidades en el mundo que nos rodea.
Y esa búsqueda es por lo que tantas experiencias
que iniciaron con simple deleite y diversión
finalmente nos llevaron a grandes avances profundos.
Creo que esto tiene implicaciones sobre cómo enseñamos a los niños en la escuela
y cómo fomentamos la innovación en nuestro trabajo,
pero pensar en el juego y las delicias de esta manera
también nos ayuda a detectar lo que vendrá después.
Piensa en esto: si estuviera sentado allí en 1750
tratando de averiguar los grandes cambios que vienen a la sociedad
en los siglos XIX y XX,
máquinas automáticas, computadoras,
inteligencia artificial,
una flauta programable
para entretener a la élite parisina
habría sido un indicio poderoso como cualquier otra cosa en el momento.
Parecería una diversión a lo sumo,
inútil de cualquier forma será,
pero resultó ser el comienzo de una revolución de tecnología
que iba a cambiar el mundo.
Debes encontrar el futuro
donde la gente se divierte más.